bring in Jeff passing the baseball rider
from the mothership Jeff thanks for
joining us again how close was this that
maybe if San Francisco went up another
year or the Dodgers expanded this a
little bit like Philadelphia felt like
game an offer he couldn't refuse it got
to that point at the end Anna and that
was a thing this thing stretched out as
long as it did because he was just
waiting to get not not only the
commitment in in years and in dollars
but the feeling that he's getting what
he wants and you know it paralleled
Manny Machado is for agency so much in
that regard these guys both went into
free agency believing they were worth a
particular number and they wanted to hit
that number for Manny Machado it started
with a three and four Bryce Harper it
started with a record and in the end
both of them got what they were looking
for the Dodgers offer was pretty good
it's not exactly what was out there okay
I think that I I think the 45 million a
year for four years that's out there is
exaggerated I it was from what sources
have told we though something that would
have paid him in the first couple of
years potentially 40-plus million
dollars and included an opt-out after
that second and it's a really
interesting thing to consider Dan
because let's just look at this
mathematically if we can I know math is
hard I know that's not fun but just for
a second let's look at this let's say
that Bryce Harper would have gotten paid
42 and a half million dollars each of
those first two years and he comes off
of you know maybe not like an MVP
winning season that second year but a
season where he hits 35 home runs and
has an LPS of 975 you know patrols
left-field or right-field wherever he's
playing well
all of a sudden you've got a guy who's
made 85 million dollars in two years and
is hitting free agency coming off a
better year than this last one that he's
had and it's still only 28 years old so
Bryce Harper theoretically if he does
that we'll go out and break the bank
still we'll get 300 plus million and
already 185 million there he didn't want
that
he just didn't and I understand why you
know I wrote a column that talked about
some of these meetings that he had and
in these meetings he and his wife Kayla
kept using the word family and I don't
mean to sound trite and I'm not trying
to be all like Mike Hampton I signed
with the Rockies because of the school
districts but you know I think this
really mattered to Bryce Harper feeling
loved and wanting to commit to a place
because he has no opt-outs and a full no
trade clause which means he can't spend
13 years with the Philadelphia Phillies
and that is completely up to him whether
he wants to yourself yeah and I think
it's a it worked out for both sides
which usually doesn't happen it
certainly with the Scott Boras client
and Philadelphia I think at least for
the next seven to nine years they might
look at this and say we got a hell of a
bargain I don't know what the backend of
this is going to look like but for the
time being and they can add some pieces
here they had a good off season prior to
getting Harper now it's been a great
offseason for Philadelphia if you're
looking at where they rank now with the
other national league teams are they
ahead of the Dodgers
potentially I you know there's the
questions I think about the depths of
the Phillies rotation Aaron Ola is as
wonderful as he was last year the notion
of him repeating that as a difficult
thing to do you know maybe he is that
guy who can go out and put back-to-back
siyoung type Caesars on the board Jake
Arrieta you know there are questions
about yeah hey speaking of putting
back-to-back cyanotype seasons on the
board he he hasn't done that he's got a
little older I personally love Nick
pavetta
I think he's a guy who's primed for a
breakout and and if he can be that guy
and they have they have a sneaky
potentially good bullpen to and and the
big thing with the Phillies they gave
they gave away so many runs last year
with just absolutely awful fielding and
I don't think they're gonna do that this
year I think they're their gloves are
gonna be a whole lot better around the
diamond and if you know if they can save
some runs with those gloves they're
gonna hit and they're gonna hit really
well there in that ballpark they may
lead the National League in runs scored
that's I mean that ballpark and that
lineup it's gonna be really really good
talking to Jeff Passan baseball insider
from ESPN joining us from Arizona also
wondering this more likely to hit the
open market or resign with their teams
if I look at Mookie Betts in Boston I
look at Aaron judge in New York and I'm
looking at Mike Trout in Los Angeles
who's more likely to hit the open market
out of those three bets oh really okay
yeah yeah I got the feeling judge is not
this isn't his style that that the
Yankees will probably try to lock him up
I'm gonna guess arty Moreno and the
angels are going to do their best to
lock up Mike Trout and won one would
believe however what let's remember this
and this was something that that didn't
go unspoken with Bryce Harper's contract
like you know there were allusions to it
when I was talking with people yesterday
and and that allusion was used in the
word flexibility and if you look at
Harper's deal the sillies wanted to
stretch it over 13 years because they
understood that when you're talking
about calculating the luxury tax that
number comes from the average annual
value and the average annual value of
Manny Machado is deal for example is
thirty million dollars Bryce Harper's is
only twenty five point four million so
that means whatever the luxury tax
threshold becomes and it's going to be a
lot higher
after this collective bargaining
agreement I think whatever it becomes
though twenty five million dollars is a
really comfortable number for the
Phillies to be at and it gives them the
flexibility to go out and I don't know
say like spend forty million dollars a
year on a kid from Millville New Jersey
I mean I mean just saying that's a
possibility
it's know what there was like there was
like an across the country like wink
wink that that was sent yesterday from
Philadelphia to Mike Trout and hey buddy
we got one come and make it to will be
waiting in traffic listen that's not a
free agent until after the twenty season
but but I think you know I think when
you look at what Mike Trout is going to
warrant because he is like the best
player I've ever seen the best player in
a generation potentially
I'm just saying potentially the best
player ever like that's the kind of
start that he's add to his career he's
gonna warrant 12 years and four hundred
million dollars
I'll just say that right now and the
last time our team Rayna signed a guy
past age forty was Albert Pujols and
Artie Moreno also signed a centerfielder
through his mid to late thirties and
that was Josh Hamilton and between those
two that's like four hundred million
dollars or so that have not turned out
particularly well we got some time to
digest that one though Jeff thank you
it's always great work covering this and
have fun in spring training
thank you that's a Jeff Passan baseball
insider from the mothership if you
missed any of our interviews this week
from the mercedes-amg man cave go to the
Dan Patrick show app where you can watch
and listen from inside the mercedes-amg
man cave mercedes-amg
driving performance for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]